[Music]
hello and welcome to learn the night
ourf with me Caleb
this is a new series that I'm starting
of course and I'm hoping it'll be sort
of the spiritual successor to my
favorite series on the YouTube channel
learning about it with Lulu of course
this is the idea of these series is that
we're introducing all these new ideas
and perhaps they're they're sort of new
to the instructor as well I am by no
means an expert on the night or if
coming into this series and so I wanted
to take it week by week looking at lines
doing a ton of prep for the lecture that
way the material is still fresh fresh to
me and so I know which ideas are kind of
more confusing because I can tell you
which ideas confused me and then how I
ended up figuring out those
complications and arriving at some kind
of logical variation so to kick off the
series I wanted to start with the Bishop
e2 line of the night off because it's
sort of seen as more of a positional
style of game rather than the absurd
crazy now turf lines that are just
totally theory heavy and end up in some
kind of tactical mess so starting with
Bishop e2 was great and I don't think
I'm even going to get through all of the
variations in the Bishop e2 lines but
we're gonna make some good headway this
week in the first installment of the
series and without further ado let's get
into it here the knight or F of course
arises after E for let me actually flip
we have c5 Knight f3 d6 d4 for the open
Sicilian C takes d4 Knight takes d4
Knight f6 attacking the e4 pawn and so
Knight c3 by white and now a6 is the
starting position of the knight or
variation a6 of course is the
multi-purpose move just as a short
introduction to the knight orff one idea
is to prevent any of these pieces from
coming to the b v square this is a
useful square for white and many
variations for example if you play the
movie 5 here Bishop e5 check is already
very
very good for white with night at 5:00
coming so a six guarding the be five
square first and foremost
secondly it is actually a preparatory
move for black to play b5 himself in
many variations so this is the idea of
the night or taking away this b5 square
on this move five now there are many
many different ways that white can play
against the night or if and it is it
does kind of have a reputation as one of
the most complex chess openings out
there so today as I said we're starting
with this move Bishop e2 six Bishop e2
is the line we're looking at today and
the knight earth way to play is with
this move now he five kicking this night
away highlighting the fact that we've
guarded this square so we don't have to
worry about any of those checking ideas
or might be five ideas now there are
actually two moves here for white in
this position the move Knight a5 isn't
really a move because the move d5 is
gonna be a good response so Knight f3
and Knight B three are the two main
moves here for white an IP three has
been played many many more times but
Knight f3 lately has been kind of made
popular by the world champion Magnus
Carlsen so to start with today I'm gonna
look at the more popular variation with
93 the idea here is that's well of
course we're moving this removing the
snake from capture but we're not
blocking this F pawn we're not blocking
this diagonal and this is going to
afford white a few more opportunities
now from what I've seen all the ideas in
this variation are pretty similar for
black almost no matter what's white
plays there's a few kind of main setups
that are important to know so right here
I wanted to kind of introduce a few of
those one set up is with bringing all
these pieces to their most natural
square eventually and then black if he
goes for this setup is gonna look to
play on the Queen side but stuff like
rook c8 Queen c7 bringing this night
either to c4 or up to c5 going for
things like b5 and b4 as well obviously
that's a lot of arrows but we'll get
into those lines a little bit as well
another set up is actually with
yes of course this bishop here but then
perhaps developing a little bit of a
less standard way well I guess it is
pretty standard but just just a
different way from the first thing we I
drew on the board there with this bishop
coming out to be seven highlighting the
fact that the e4 pawn can sometimes be
weak and additionally depending on what
happens you you will sometimes see this
knight come to c6 rather than b7 or
rather than d7 and so we'll talk about
that that as well
usually this king does end up castling
kingside almost regardless but you know
all of this in good time so moving along
here I will say that it is rather
important for black to kind of delay the
natural looking move Bishop e6 of course
it's all about the d5 square and many of
these variations so Bishop e6 looks very
natural but white does have a rather
strong reply here and that reply is
going to be this move f4 f4 is now
creating some threats of playing the
move at five creating threats in the
center and with this bishop on e6
already this is going to be a little bit
difficult for black to me for example if
Queen c7 already a move like g4 and
these things are coming with tempo
rather quickly so instead of playing the
move it should be six and with Bishop e7
is by far more common just delaying this
and now if the move f4 does come on the
board this is going to be a lot less
scary for black because the move f5
won't be coming with tempo and of course
we're not playing the move Bishop e6
here but more on that at a later date
for the moment we're gonna focus on move
eight castles this is kind of the main
topic of the lecture tonight move eight
castles here this is by far the most
common move and we'll look at why so
there are a few different ways to play
here for black as well I'm going to
recommend that you actually still stay
away from playing this move Bishop e6
because if you play but should be six
here the move f4 can actually still be
rather strong if Queen c7 already moves
like f5 are kind of coming with tempo
and it may not be as bad as playing but
should be six immediately but
you know these are still not the most
comfortable positions for black from
what I can tell so rather than playing
Bishop e6 castles is a perfectly natural
move for black and it's sort of the case
of you know even if you can why would
you want to play Bishop e6 because as I
said sometimes this Bishop does come out
along this other diagonal so castles is
the more flexible move and I do think it
is the better move now the main move for
whites there are a few of them but the
most popular move is Bishop III and
after this move Bishop III this is kind
of the green light to develop this
Bishop out to e6 so now why is that why
do you think white moving this Bishop to
e3 is the go-ahead for black play Bishop
e6 what do you think chat room
what do you think chat room why after
Bishop III does Bishop e6 make more
sense so better to play black or white
in the night or if in most cases it's
better to have the white pieces because
white moves first but then I door F is
one of the most well respected openings
and you know as they say chess is a draw
so I guess neither he'll lose a tempo
when we take sis Mohamed and that is
totally accurate
now after Bishop III if white wants to
play this f4 move anyways now we are
actually gonna play the movie takes f4
and compared to the other variations now
white would be recapturing at the loss
of a tempo sort of similar to this idea
that we see in the qgd we're black
delays taking on c c4 until this bishop
is moved from f1 now the move rook takes
f4 is also potentially playable here but
it's not really gonna be that
threatening for black the main advantage
of having the bishop on f4 is the
pressure you get on d6 and also actually
the pressure you get on the e5 square
and with the rook here on f4 white
doesn't really get any of that just as
an example line knight c6 and now white
had better kind of start doing things
immediately so just for example 95 we
can capture capture and just plant this
Knight onto e5 and this is gonna be a
fairly comfortable position now for
black so F fort not the most common here
although it has been tried so let's look
at what is the most common over a
thousand games in this variation with
Queen d2 and we will definitely branch
out to see more more variations later
actually let me spend a little bit more
time on f4 takes
so if rook takes f4 as I said just
knight c6 and we're aiming for
e5 if Bishop f4 instead I will say you
can just play the same way with knight
c6 and after King h1 rather than playing
you are 95 here you move d5 actually
it's sort of immediately equalizing here
from what I can tell and the point is
you're just breaking down this pawn on
e4 and if the move e5 comes in black can
immediately simplify things by 97 the
deef the e5 pawn now is just strictly
indefensible and so trades will ensue
for example here something like this and
that takes you seven Queen takes e7 and
black is is not doing any worse in this
position you can claim that White has
the two bishops but you would rather
actually have this pawn on f7 then this
pawn on c2 because it gives you a slight
slightly safer King in most cases and
the other fact of the matter is that all
of black's pieces have really reasonable
squares this knight on c6 this dad on e5
is looking at some various hops and yet
black is just doing totally totally fine
here so moving along from f4 now let's
look at this idea with Queen to d2 so
what is the point of Queen to d2 well
for one it is clearing the back rank
allowing these rooks to sort of move a
little bit more freely it's also well I
guess that is kind of the main point
it's also you know keeping it a closer
eye on some dark squares here so for
example if some crazy thing like 98 now
the g5 square is already well in whites
grasp but main point clearing the back
rank for some of these rooks
now I think the most natural development
here for black is to come to the d7
square with the knight and this is sort
of that main setup I was talking about
we're already sort of arriving at it
here with with black you just get all
the pieces out and now as I said we're
looking for play on the Queen side stuff
like Erick c8 stuff like Queen c7
stuff like b5 stuff like Knight b6 to c4
or potentially just Knight to c5 these
are sort of the the big ideas here and
this is one of the main main setups for
black that you can employ here against
these these Bishop b2 lines
now if white isn't careful the move b5
is going to come on the board and b5 is
sort of exactly what's black is aiming
for here so by far the main main move
here is a 4/4 white
to prevent this idea and now I'm going
to recommend the move rook c8 it's nice
and solid
super simple you're looking at this
backward pawn on c2 well not yet
backward but for the moment loosely
defended pawn on c2 as I said you're
also looking at the c5 square and the
c-4 square and these are very - very
much too relevant squares in this
opening now if white sort of takes is
time again we can kind of just go for
this Knight b6 to c4 idea and this idea
is good enough that I think it's worth
preventing for white so most common move
now by far is the move a5 to prevent
this exact idea now the move Queen c7
can come on the board and there are two
moves here for white rook F to d1 and
rook F 2 c1 generally this rook can't
really be touched because first and
foremost this pawn is sort of hanging
although immediately I'm blundering some
tactics but this pawn is gonna be under
defended if you play the move Knight c5
here so just for example now this work
is already having to come back so this
rook kind of stuck on a1 that's why
these are in the two moves with the F
rook just to keep the a pawn a little
bit more closely defended so let's look
at look F 2 c1 first the idea of this
move of course is to defend the C pawn
allow this Knight a little bit of
mobility if it ever needs it and from
here the counter-intuitive moved
slightly Knight c5 does seem to be good
enough for black now we're at this point
we are just following a game between
which game is this oh yes a game between
Ivanchuk and Kramnik all the way back in
2004 and that game went with Knight
takes e5 d
take c5 and from here there are once
again sort of two ways to play for white
you can go the concrete approach with an
immediate 95 now that this file is well
blocked and the threats on c2 are no
more or you can go for a slower approach
with f3 so looking at the immediate 95
first here you can simply take this
night play Bishop d6 c4 97 just f3 for
example and already f5 and the point of
this position is this pawn is protected
and passed it's true but the play on the
queenside has very much slowed down
Black has really great control of the c5
square which is really the only
breakthrough point for white I mean if
you're not playing B 4 + c5 then really
what are you doing with white on the
queenside and black can sort of Riemann
over his pieces to support these kinds
of advances on the Kings side now if you
are a fan of chess Abul and specifically
Alex korvac Karlovich I'm forgetting his
name you may recognize this position and
I do want to be open that I have
actually looked at this chest full
course a little bit and some of these
lines are gonna end up being somewhere
to his but I do think I'm offering
enough unique and ideas for my own brain
that this is not just copying his course
so if you do want a rather complete
course on the knight or please check out
his course as well and this is a line
that he did recommend and it does look
quite nice for black in the meantime
though I don't think 95 is actually the
best try for white because this sort of
line is is really rather forcing and at
this point I think black is is doing
really really well here it does really
feel like black is the one with all the
active ideas in this specific line as I
said if white really can't get b4 in and
for the moment it looks as though he
can't then white doesn't have any
divide ia's on the queenside so this one
looks good for black in my opinion now
the move f3 this is a little bit more of
a flexible approach of course you are
not immediately going for this locked
down structure on the queenside and
because of that it is actually allowing
black some opportunities here for
example the move c4 is the big idea now
for black it's sort of a case where
white didn't play 95 and c4 well II
could so black should go for it now and
if white plays something nonchalance
black has a really nice idea I'm playing
a move like Bishop c5 and trading off
these bishops in many many cases which
is why the main move here is a knight a
4 it's the move that Ivanchuk played in
his game against kramnik and now white
is aiming for these squares and so 97 is
contesting those squares quite nicely
now if Bishop F 1 this is the move
played in the game of Ivan chick and
Kramnik black once again has a few ideas
here
rook d8 at first glance looks really
really natural and this is actually
what's Kramnik played in his game but a
little bit later on in that game
black sort of ran out of ideas and I was
as I was looking at this position I was
also very much struggling to come up
with these ideas for black here kramnik
kind of just started shuffling around
and and actually made a mistake or two
by bringing this queen out to be 5 and
allowing some b3 tactics on this long
diagonal so rather than rook da time
actually gonna suggest a different move
here and that move is f5 and this move
is a lot less intuitive than rift e8 but
the idea is now it is really once again
going to be black with all the active
ideas which is why I very much do like
this line he takes that v is really the
only move that makes any sense if you
don't take this pawn if you pass for
example now the move f4 is going to be
good for black the move F takes e4 is
also just going to be a better version
for black with this active rook on the F
file
he takes a five kind of has to be played
and now I move like rook takes that five
is very very sensible now after letting
the engine run for quite a bit the best
it come up with is the move Knight b6
here for white and if this is the best
that white can do then white can't do
very very well at all this is just a
simplifying move when after Bishop c5
take on c5 take on c5 King edge one the
movie 4 is really blacks last challenge
if black plays efore I think black
should honestly be better if he gets
this move and once again because of the
King's safety in this case the F pawns
would be equal after something like
Bishop d5e 4 takes takes but because the
g2 pawn is a light colored pawn I do
think it would once again be black with
a slight advantage here because the
pressure on g2 is gonna be a lot more
relevant than the pressure on h7 in my
opinion a reason for that is the move h6
there's a lot more comfortable to play
than the move g3 and so once again I
quite like blacks chances here that's
not to say white is doing much worse I
said black is better if he can get me
foreign but before of course has not yet
been played and so there is still some
work to be done here for black but I do
quite like this line with the immediate
f5 in response to did this type of play
from white so once again this all
happened after the move rook F c1 the
idea of controlling c2 we play the move
Knight c5 to challenge the e pawn white
kind of also of course this night at b3
why it kind of has to take otherwise
Bishop e3 and Knight b3 is just a little
bit too strong it's d c5 and then rather
than 95 which would allow black this
easy structure the move f3 is a little
bit slower and so black plays c4 opening
up this diagonal and then we go 97 and
f5 and this is kind of the main idea
that I looked at here now rather than
rook F 2 c1 of course the move rook F 2
d1 is very playable as well and against
this move
we are going to play the move rook F to
d8 you know pretty sensible right this
turret comes here our rook comes here
and now after Queen e1 once again the
move Knight c5 is very much playable
Knight c5 Knight takes e5 D takes e5 and
we get something similar to what we just
looked at with the key difference that
the move Knight d5 isn't really even
playable in this specific case because
of course this is just a free pawn now
if white kind of revert s' and plays a
move like f3 what's the difference here
well not rip d2 but rook takes d1 Bishop
takes d1 and c4 and once again we we
kind of get something similar with one
set of rooks off the board though it's
it's not going to be too too different
for example 9a 497 and once again ideas
of f5 are kind of in the air for black
so instead takes d8 or takes d8 King h1
is one way to play now the move between
c6 and we are following now Ivanchuk
with white pieces again this time
against look ven Bailey I can't say his
name I apologize but now f3 c4 and once
again it's very similar stuff to what we
were looking at with the addendum that
95 once again is rather impossible
Bishop F 1 was played in the game and
now King f8 was of an Whaley's choice
and the idea here is that King f8 is
actually move that creates a threat
believe it or not there is a very
favorable move that black would have
liked to play in the last turn but was
unable to so see if you guys can answer
at home what that very favorable move
black wanted to play was and then why
King f8 allows him to play it you know
cuz there's some reason why this
favorable move a favorable move does not
work in this case there's a tactical
line and then King f8 sort of creates
the threat so who knows it
who knows
yeah rook d2 was rather shocking King f8
suspicious
well it looks suspicious but it is
actually very very logical once you see
the idea
memento mori says MVL has inspired him
to play the no Dorothea mvl is sort of
the main proponent of the night or in
modern captain chess queen g3 would come
with a tempo so actually not quite the
idea is black really would love to play
this move Bishop b4 this should be
forced sort of locks down White's entire
play on the Queen side but unfortunately
tactically this move is not so good
because of the move 95 95 and now all of
a sudden these are all threats in the
position for example this should take C
197 check King f8 the Knight takes c6 B
takes c6 Bishop c5 is a Czech king yeah
we'll say rook takes c1 and white is
substantially better here so this Knight
d5 move is sort of the main reason why
King f8 was played in the game King f8
creating the threat of Bishop b4 so that
95 is not good enough and then of course
white not wanting to allow this place
the move Knight a 497 but this is an
important idea to keep in mind
so if Bishop b4 is ever playable for you
you should definitely keep an eye on it
and try to play this move if your
opponent prevents it and of course you
can't but this is sort of the reason
behind King f8 and that's why it's not
such a bad move after all night a for
Knight d7 played in the game Queen c3
rook c8 Queen d2 458 Queen c3 rook c8
Queen d2 rook t8 was good enough for for
a draw here neither player really
willing to deviate here if for example
rather than Queen d2 white try does
something like Queen e1 h6 is generally
a useful move for black to include
keeping ideas of Bishop g5 alive and if
this Knight ever steps back to c3 then
this Bishop comes to p4 once again and
if the snake doesn't step to c3 it's
sort of a
of all of the white pieces kind of being
locked down why white doesn't want to
play the move beef be three because this
is definitely going to favor black if
you don't take this immediately it is
going to be weak in the long run and
where else is this not going to go it
can't really move
if this Knight can't move then this rook
can't move this Bishop can't go anywhere
White's definitely not trying to open
things up on the Kings side with stuff
like f4 or anything because this pawn is
weak and that's just sort of a case
where white doesn't have any active
ideas and it very well may be that black
doesn't have any good act of ideas here
either but that just means that you're
gonna get something like this
grandmaster draw that we saw here with
Queens c3 and Queen d2 just it's tough
to to make something happen here for
white you know my experience when that's
the case more often than not players
with white pieces might get a little
frustrated and try something that
perhaps they shouldn't so once again key
idea to keep in mind here Knight c3
Bishop b4 locks down all of the white
pieces okay and that is I think all the
lines that I wanted to look at involving
this move Bishop e3 this is by far the
main main line in this castles variation
and I know where we're moving through
rather quickly here but there is just so
so much content to cover in Dorf that
I'm trying to fit it all into something
a little bit more digestible so as a
quick review Bishop e3 is our go-ahead
to play Bishop e6 because now f4 is a
little bit less intuitive because after
takes and takes white is losing a tempo
and then we go 96 and d5 so rather than
f4 white would rather play a move like
Queen d2 and now we go Knight bd7
with the ideas of playing Roxy 8 and 96
to c4 if we're allowed or in most cases
as we see here we're settling for 95
because a4 a5 is White's idea to slow us
down
so a four-by-four the main move rook c8
a5 preventing Knight b6 to c4 Queen c7
rooked
rook da or rook F to c1 and the
immediate Knight c5 the idea once again
being that this structure is pretty good
for black the idea bringing this Knight
to d7 and pushing at five when white is
sort of blocked on the Queen side and if
white takes his time these ideas of
playing in early f5 here are the ones
that I like rook d1 is more of the same
with 95 quickly to follow and more of
these ideas of playing c4 and arriving
at these types of positions where
everything is just a bit locked down and
we arrive at this draw in the Ivanchuk
event valley are then valley then Whaley
I can't say his name in there game okay
moving along I wanted to take a look at
another line here let's look from blacks
perspective again in the night or F
arriving here Knight b3 Bishop e7
castles castles and now rather than
Bishop e3 we saw Bishop e3 as the
go-ahead to develop our Bishop out to e6
because white sometimes wants to keep
keep these f4 ideas alive you'll see
them play this sort of cagey move King
to h1 and this is a very very clever
waiting move the idea is now if we do
play the move Bishop e6 now f4 is coming
on the board once again and king h1 is a
very very useful move for white to have
included here so after takes takes it's
not as the white is losing a tempo he's
used this tempo to bring his King off of
this long diagonal that is now open so
this is something that I believe blacks
should should very much try to avoid and
the other idea of this is that if the
move b5 comes on the board this is sort
of an intuitive good move for black
immediately the move a4 comes on the
board to challenge these pawns that's
more or less is asking black to play the
move b4 and now Knight d5 and if we take
this guy Queen takes and rook a 7 and
this just isn't the most comfortable now
for for black definitely is some
untangling has to be done and
like this so rather than sort of obliged
white and play one of these moves that
he's hoping to see the move b6 has
become the main reply here for black in
response to king h1 and the idea of b6
is it's just like b5 except now a 4
isn't going to be immediately going down
these lines where b4 is forced for black
and that give white this kind of
initiative so now once again there are a
couple ways to play if you do see the
move Bishop e3 now after b6 of course we
are aiming for the second setup that I
mentioned with this bishop coming out to
be 7 and we are just challenging the f3
pawn now after f3
having seen white waste these two Tempe
on Bishop e3 and f3 and having gotten
this Bishop out to be 7 to control d5
black is now much better prepared to
meet a 4 so that's why you see the move
b5 be played here a 4 is still by far
the most popular response for white in
response to this move and after B 495 we
can simply take this guy and of course
Queen takes is no longer at playable
with our Bishop here on b7 so he takes
d5 instead and now just to move like 97
and it's going to be a comfortable game
once again for black the ideas revolving
around this d5 pawn actually being a
little bit weakened a little bit
overextended perhaps and that's why you
see moves like c3 or c4
either way black can take and now Bishop
g5 is a good move for black in many many
cases to activate this Bishop for
example Bishop f2 Queen c7 c4 a5 getting
the bishop out in this manner 92 Bishop
takes d2 and this was good enough for
June June to get a pretty favorable
endgame eventually in her game against
Anna mozi trick and the Women's World
Championship back in 2010 Joo and June
had this with the black pieces and did
actually end up winning what should have
been a drone Rick end game but she
definitely did have in the favorable
side once again the ideas just Bishop a6
and black has a nice hold on the
queenside
no real weaknesses for white to look at
you could argue maybe this upon an a5
but black with very much
- solid weaknesses that he can sort of
he or she in this case can sink his or
her teeth into and that's why we saw Joe
and Jun go on to win this game
so the idea Bishop e3 and now after
Bishop e7 sort of forcing after he to
defend this pawn now black has to go
ahead to play b5 now understandably
players with the white pieces have sort
of wanted to avoid allowing black to get
all this space with b5 now that you're
adequately prepared to meet Knight d5
with this Bishop on p7 because of that
they have started kind of delaying this
Bishop e3 move and either playing a4
immediately or first defending this pawn
this should be seven and then playing a
for the idea now being of course and
that b5 is prevented before it ever got
started this is why they have delayed
developing this Bishop to financial III
now in this case I am going to talk
about this move a for a little bit and
why white isn't just always planning it
right it seems like a very very useful
move in pretty much every case here
because b5 is a useful move for black in
pretty much every case so why doesn't
white just always play this move a4
before b5 ever happens and the reason
for that from what I can tell is that it
does come with a pretty significant
downside in that downside is that this B
4 square now falls under blacks control
so pretty much in every line that I've
looked at where a4 ends up getting
played in these types of positions that
is sort of the green light to develop
this night not to d7 but instead to c6
so in most cases this Knight comes to d7
looks for ideas of Knight b6 to c4 or
alternatively Knight to c5 as we saw in
those first variations but now with this
pawn to a4 you want to bring this knight
to c6 and the reason for that of course
is because white has loosened his grip
on this B 4 square and from B for this
night doesn't
excellent job of protecting d5 and as
always in the night or it's about the d5
square so 96 here is the recommendation
now at Bishop g5 is the main move trying
to loosen blacks grip on this d5 square
but now the simple night b4 and now thus
night on b4 is so strong in fact that in
all 28 times this position has been
reached the move Knight to be 1 has been
played the simple idea here being c3
would remove this Knight from its b4
outpost and this is sort of a necessity
at this point for white to get rid of
this night and now the move a5 is
actually very very nice for black and
this is how the game went in Ivan shook
against audubon Ivan shook reaching
these kinds of positions with the white
pieces a lot and a myriad of players
reaching them with the black pieces here
and in that game the move Knight a3 was
chosen not immediately kicking the
knight back if c3 does get played here
the point of a5 was to grant our Knight
this a 6 square when now it's coming to
the very very natural c5 square to
follow notably this I do think is a
better version of the lines we were
looking at before because with this pawn
on c3 there's no Knight ready to jump
into d5 and this nighttime b1 is not
really ideally placed for for white here
in the game though 93 was played
defending this guy and because now this
night has not been booted away
Audubon took the opportunity to play d5
and was doing absolutely fine in this
game against Ivan shook c3 Knight a6
takes takes d5 Bishop d5 and it's pretty
clear to see that black should not be
any worse here with an extra pawn in the
center and the two bishops black is
doing totally totally fine here and the
game continued for a bit but black found
himself in no real danger this Knight
coming to c5 and excellent control over
the light squares in the white camp here
and actually I guess the game didn't
last too long or KD one Bishop c8 rack
Fe
and actually no the game did last a long
long time I was wrong it's just the
annotation was put here this was
Ivanchuk audubon from the tournament of
peace in 2018 okay
and so that is sort of the story of the
move nine King H won once again this is
a waiting move by white trying to blade
trying to bait black and applying one of
the two natural moves against Bishop e6
now f4 has gained in power with this
Bishop coming to f4 in one turn and
against b5 a4 is a pretty good reply for
white which is why the move b6 is the
most popular move for black not allowing
white either of these opportunities with
a4 or F 4 now if Bishop e3 play
continues very naturally like this with
b5 to follow now that we're prepared to
meet a 4b 495 and if white tries to be
clever and plays a 4 that gives up
control of the key B 4 square so we play
the move knight c6 this is sort of the
logical flow of things against this move
King h1 so now we've looked at a few
things so far just to recap where we are
we've looked at the move 9 Bishop e3 and
a lot of the ideas surrounding it we've
looked at the move 9 King h1 and a lot
of the ideas surrounding it now I want
to look at a kind of strange-looking
idea with the move Queen to d3 and the
ideas involved in that so let's go ahead
and move right along and jump into it
fun smart content this is part 1 of the
series 1 in the night or with me Caleb
look for all the rest of the night or of
lines in the coming weeks
I plan to be doing this for a while yeah
Queen d3 question my question mark there
will likely be a part 2 of the Bishop e2
lines because today I'm mostly focusing
on the lines where white ends up
castling and there are plenty of lines
or white does not castle in these
variations Kings side at least so once
again we have an eider starting position
I don't know why I'm making it with my
mouse when I could just scroll Bishop e2
'if I've 93 Bishop e7
castles castles and now either queen d3
immediately or Bishop III and then queen
d3 is also a very popular line but the
idea is the same so Queen to d3 what is
the purpose of this strange odd-looking
move Queen to d3 well it's actually
pretty simple the idea is you're
defending the e4 pawn why is it
important to defend the e4 pawn
well because white wants to play the
move Knight to d5 without losing a pawn
on e4 so Queen d3 the idea of Knight to
d5 now against this you can actually
play the move Bishop e6 so this is sort
of the secondary green light to play the
move Bishop e6 green light number one
was if you saw the move Bishop e3
because then takes is fine for black
after F for green light number two is
this move Queen d3 and the reason this
move also allows you to play the move
Bishop e6 is because it makes this
diagonal rather awkward for white
meaning after f4 you do have the option
to play the move b5 here the point being
if f5 this is quite comfortable now for
black so f4 would be met with b5 which
is why this never really gets played
now after Bishop e6 there are a few main
ideas for white one is to play the move
Knight d5 immediately another is to play
the move Bishop e3 which once again you
can kind of interchange these moves as
neat as you want with the white pieces
but it doesn't really make a difference
because against Bishop b3 we would have
played Bishop e6 anyways so that's 95
Bishop e3 and there's also a new idea of
the move Bishop to d2 so let's look at
all three ideas why don't we start here
with the move Knight to d5 the idea here
is you just immediately plant this night
on this square and this is a perfectly
fine way of playing now black actually
does have quite a lot of options if you
want to go for simplicity you can just
play the move Knight B to d7 here and
now either Bishop d2 or Bishop e3 or
really be
but moves for white and these would of
course transpose to the other lines but
the move 95 does actually grant you a
rather unique opportunity to capture
this not with the night
sorry not with the bishop but rather
with the night both of these moves are
playable but when possible it is rather
nice to take this with the night drop
this Bishop back to c8 and the point now
is that without the knight on f6 black
is a little bit more free to start
pushing things like f5 this Bishop still
on the board can potentially later come
out to be 7 and it's just gonna be a
pretty free game for black but honestly
if you want to be simple Knight bd7
transposes to the main stuff so that's
95 now let's look at first the move
Bishop e3 this is the most popular move
and now I think the move Knight B to d7
is rather sensible if you do play the
move Knight to d5 here this is the main
idea and the point now for white by
delaying 95 for a turn this night has
landed on the d7 square and because of
that this is no longer an option because
this bishop would find itself with
nowhere to go so that's why Bishop takes
Knight instead he takes and now there
are many many many moves here for for
black I am gonna recommend the most
popular move Knight liate with similar
ideas to what we looked at with the
bishop setting on c8 you just want to
push this pawn out to to f5 and go about
your business there
for example a 4 to kind of lock things
down and now this Bishop can also come
out to g5 and another added bonus of not
having this Knight back here on f6 now
a5 still makes sense and from here apply
can continue bring your rook to c8
guarding against C pawn c4 for example
and now stuff like f5 and and g6 and
it's another one of those cases where
black is just going to be pushing on the
King side in the center and another one
of those cases where for the moment
White's plan the Queen side is
a little bit's vague will say it's a
little bit unclear how exactly white is
coming through with these moves B 4 and
C 5 of course the ideas for white are
pretty clear you want to play B 4 and C
5 but the specifics on how you're
actually getting there are rather
difficult if these bishops get traded
off the board and this night lands on c5
I mean how are you ever going to achieve
these moves I am not so sure so I do
quite like this position here for black
just for an example line Bishop takes g5
Queen takes g5 f4 is a good move in
general for white to slow down this kind
of counter play Queen h6f e5 and not de
5 giving white killer passed pawns but
rather 95 and this is once again just a
playable position for black backing on
up here let's look at the move Bishop d2
this is sort of a newer idea so why put
this Bishop on d2 rather and they in the
e3 square who understands the idea of
bringing a bishop out to d2
you and your 600 l o opponents will
never reach this
can I show liens from Lee chest with
lower than 1,800 players one day well
night out the the goal of the lecture is
not so much that you are consistent like
always reaching these exact positions
it's more that you understand the plans
and the positions and the logic behind
them if you understand the logic of
these moves that's good for your chest
in in general I will say that below 600
opening lectures don't have as as much
significance it's at that level it's
more about principles getting your
pieces out things things of that nature
the study is private how do you follow
along I guess I will have to make the
study public that is my mistake
so right after the lecture go ahead and
check out the link for now though
hopefully just follow along with the
video here
like I can't unfortunately on the flight
make it public as I am NOT using the
account it was created on ok there are
some ideas here to not allow f5f for
allowing Bishop takes i/o he's talking
about the sozin got it
to control before to not provoke D 5 D 4
so actually the idea is not so much
about controlling before here although
that is a pretty interesting idea
with the point being that the square is
weakened after a 4 it's not so much
about D 5 D 4 or F 5 F 4 either if
actually about restricting blacks play
on the queenside and in that sense it's
about controlling the a v square because
white is controlling the a v square now
suddenly the move Knight a5 is going to
be an idea in many many variations here
and this move both puts pressure on the
queenside pawns and kind of prevents the
queenside pawns from expanding because
then the move knight c6 would be rather
difficult to deal with
so that is Bishop d2 that is the power
efficient b2 still though you can just
develop naturally with Knight B to d7 95
of course is the idea with Queen d3 here
we still have Bishop takes d5 he takes
d5 and now there are actually a couple
ways to play I kind of prefer the most
direct play of playing with 98 once
again the same idea we saw it with
Bishop e3 and I'll explore it in a
little bit more depth here it really is
just kind of the same or you can kind of
play against White's setup with the move
a5 and this is sort of from what I've
seen that the safer way of playing for
black but I think it's also less likely
to give you a position that that you can
kind of win so the idea of a5 of course
is you're preventing the move and Knight
a5 and play might continue with a for
blocking the a pawn b6
c4 Knight c5 takes takes and it is a
very very safe structure for black on
the Queen side but at the same time now
white is going to have time to kind of
Riemann over these bishops and start
aiming at blacks King side as well it's
gonna make it very very difficult I
think for black to actually get anything
done with these bishops always
threatening to come into play if the
position ever does actually open up so I
instead prefer the move Knight e8 and
this move sort of gives what gives white
what he wanted with this move Knight a5
and now we do sort of more clearly see
the idea of this move it's gonna be very
difficult to touch these Queen side
pawns now for black with this Knight
jumping into c6 at a moment's notice but
the move rook b8 is sort of keeping the
balance on the Queen side just defending
the b-pawn now for example the move c4
is sort of what white is trying to do
here with b4 + c5 to follow but now we
can immediately start our counter play
on the Kings side with a move like f5
and just as an example line now if b4
Bishop c5 is always a good idea for what
for black here to activate this Bishop
there should be one would be preventing
the trade and already a move like a flow
is coming on the board and after Queen
c2 you see the the difference here where
rather than having these bishops sort of
lining up to look at the Kings side we
have these bishops kind of stuck on the
e-file where it's true that they're
controlling the Queen side but it comes
at the cost of allowing black a little
bit more freedom to expand over here on
on the Kings side himself so for example
I move like 95 is coming move like Queen
e7 and for the moment I do not see the
breakthrough for white which is why I
don't really mind allowing this move in
Knight a5 because I do think blacks play
on the Kings side is coming in time as I
said though this is sort of a little bit
of a riskier approach because this is
kind of the pawn structure white is
aiming for but I do think blacks play is
is coming quite quickly just as an
example Queen e7 or it could be one and
so yeah moves like 95 it was like Bishop
f4 even and these ponds are gonna start
rolling up the board before too long
okay so that is sort of the idea of this
98 the ship g5 stuff is you just start
pushing these pawns in the center and go
for counter play there once again the
alternative rather than 98 you can play
the move a5 to stop this Knight from
landing on the a5 square okay how am i
doing on time 10 minutes left
we're rolling we're rolling so as
another recap so far we are looking at
Bishop e2 line 6e 5 I am definitely not
getting to the move Knight f3 in this
lecture which was introduced well I
guess not introduced but made popular by
Magnus Carlsen instead the main move
Knight b3 Bishop e7 and we're looking at
castles castles and here we have seen
Bishop e3 we have seen the move King h1
and now we have seen Queen d3 in these
95 ideas so hopefully you have an idea
of how to play against all of those
these are really the most popular ideas
here in the Bishop b2 variation and now
to wrap up the lecture I wanted to look
at one last really interesting idea by
white rather than
all of these moves which have different
ideas Bishop III King h1 and Queen d3
what if the move a4 happens immediately
and with this move let me actually click
over to the next chapter here looking at
nine a4 from the black site with this
move once again it's gonna be a story of
the be four square this move gives away
in the square on b4 now the most popular
move here for black is actually this
move this should be six but honestly I'm
not so comfortable with this move Bishop
e6 because still the move f4 is a very
playable idea for white and I do think
that the move a four is going to be
reasonably useful here for white
compared to the line that we looked at
where you know you could achieve this
position just kind of directly without
the pawn on a4 I do think this is a
useful inclusion
so rather than Bishop e6 I do think the
move knight c6 makes a little bit more
sense once again pawn lands on a fork
Knight goes to c6 because the B 4 square
is weak now there are once again various
options here for white let's start with
the move f4 and why I think knight c6 is
a little bit better than Bishop e6 here
you could sort of transpose to the
Bishop e6 lines by taking here and just
playing Bishop e6 but I do think that
black can do slightly better here with
the nice move Knight B 4 and this is
sort of the point of delaying the
development of this Bishop once again
now f4 comes with a less direct threat
and black has the opportunity to play
moves like Knight before going for these
ideas of d5 so I don't know how many
times I can say it when the pawn lands
on a 4 that's the go-ahead to bring this
neck to c6 and aim for these night
before ideas
okay King edge one and now once again
there are some very serious
complications here I spent some time in
this position before the lecture and I
think the move d5 may actually been
playable or maybe playable but this is
actually entirely untested I think there
is one game it looks like in the
database in this position between
players that were not very strong so I
didn't know if I could trust you know my
my lowly analysis on the move d5 and be
confident enough to recommend it here
but if d5 is playable it's a really
interesting try the play might continue
something like this and after Bishop f3
Bishop f5 it's it's gonna be some kind
of a mess here with black having a weak
D pawn white having a weak or you know
quote-unquote slightly weak epon and
good pieces in the center for black that
being said the more tried-and-true
method is either bringing this Bishop to
this diagonal via d7 and c6 or the line
that I kind of prefer here with the move
b6 directly bringing the bishop to b7
and why do I prefer this over Bishop d7
to c6 well I like having this C file
open so that we can put some major
pieces on it and kind of challenge
White's c2 pawn in in case this ever
becomes relevant now as someone in the
chat has already said now you do have
some ideas of Bishop f3 here fun smart
content apparently plays this with white
and yeah Bishop f3 is the idea rather
than pawn on f3 this Bishop takes the
role of defending the e4 pawn against
the move Bishop e7 which black is
obviously playing anyways now Bishop e3
is the natural developing idea and black
can now play the move Queen c7 and this
is sort of the reason I put this Bishop
on b7 rather than c6 now black has very
good control over the C file and if
white isn't careful for example in the
example game I chose move like Queen d2
but I can already immediately break
through with the move
the move d5 now f takes e5 here would be
a much much much better version for
black because we all we are already
targeting this pawn and this night is
coming here with tempo so II d5 is
likely the only option and now black has
this interesting idea of playing efore
in this position sort of solve all of
his problems directly and when the dust
clears we have Knight takes e4 this
Knight takes d5 rather Bishop the
spaceship should be saved so Bishop back
to G 1 and now Queen takes c2 and this
is just fizzling out into an equal
endgame here for both sides really for
example at Queen c2 9 C 2 rooks e1a at
CB 4 and nothing really going on here of
of any notes for the moment you might
think that White has a slight edge in
activity with this rook being here on c1
already but all of these squares are
pretty adequately covered and given a
couple moves
for example rook cd1 rook a to C eights
or Ric fd1 even sorry Willie white does
have to worry a little bit about this
pawn so if I move like f5 for example
already moves like 93 are potentially
playable and bringing Newark to the to
the open file is also going to be
adequate for for black here so the idea
once again this pawn comes to a 4 we
shove this night on to be 4 in response
to this F 4 idea now F 4 definitely
isn't the only option here for whites
you don't have to play like this but I
was just showing the difference between
putting this bishop on e6 and meeting F
4 with a takes F 4 and now with 96 we
have this nice option of planting the
knight on d4 so let's look at the
slightly less crazy ideas by white where
he doesn't go for throat kind of with
the move f4 and those are sort of these
ideas of Bishop f3 at some point or
Bishop g5 or Bishop e3 sort of either of
these moves
combined with Bishop f3 makes the most
sense so let's start with Bishop e3 the
natural developing move
black is gonna play Bishop e6 now and
once again we kind of see this green
light from white Bishop III and now
Bishop e6 once again because now white
would be wasting a full tempo so rather
than f4 Queen d2 is the sensible
approach that we've seen before now rook
c8 rook F to D one night before Bishop
f3 and with Bishop f3 here and due to
the way white has played putting all of
his pieces here to control d5 the move
d5 isn't actually gonna be playable in
this case we just do not have enough if
my count is correct yes white wins by
one so d5 isn't playable but now due to
the way white has played he's put a
bishop on f3 rather than a pawn and
black has this nice move Knight g4 and
now this Bishop is too important to let
die so the move Bishop takes g4 is sort
of obliged now Bishop takes hits this
rook and we have gotten rid of this
pesky Bishop on f3 and play is just
gonna kind of continue from here for
example rook a to c1 is natural to
defend this guy and now White is still
controlling d5 but we've gotten rid of
this knight on f6 which means we have
ideas of this in some positions
obviously not immediately and we also
have ideas of 5/5 which is going to be
the best move in this position I believe
already f5 and once again I think it is
black with the more active play here
wide in this line really has taken more
of a defensive approach just trying to
prevent blacks ideas and because of that
white hasn't had much success towards
generating active ideas of his own for
example the 95 is really the only thing
going for white and we can just snip
this guy off the board play Bishop d7
and it's another one of those
comfortable positions for black we're
immediately white already even has
problems on the Queen side as well so
that's Bishop e3 let's take a look at
Bishop f3 first turns out this is just
sort of a different move order night
before is once again our idea a5 now is
natural to prevents
a five by black solidifying this night
here this should be six Bishop III rook
c8 rook e1 and we are getting some
similar stuff here where White has taken
a slightly different approach we could
still go for this move Knight to to g4
with the idea of trying to pick up this
bishop but due to the way White has
played he can occasionally even just
save this bishop but something like
there should be six or even Bishop a7 so
slightly easier missed instead just play
the move d5 here the point being because
white hasn't gone Queen d2 and d1
directly we have this one tempo before
white lands on d2 to play the move d5
and tactically this is just working out
he takes d5 and that B takes d5 now if
rook d2 you would be met with Knight
takes c3 and Knight takes D one so
tonight it takes instead and now after
Bishop takes rook d2 it's met with
Bishop takes f3 so tactically these are
d2 ideas just don't work an example line
rook d2 takes takes takes takes takes
and after Knight c5 black has an extra
pawn for the moment however he's not
really going to be able to keep it with
either a 5 or b7 falling but that's not
going to be enough for an advantage for
white just for example 95 rookie 593 I
guess rookie 3 would would lose a night
so F takes c3 instead and this is just
going to be a rather equal sort of end
game once again so don't know how many
times I can stress it point of a 4 is to
stop b5 but it gives up the be 4 square
so that's Bishop f3 and Bishop e3 both
very similar ideas black goes night
before aims for d5 if white puts all he
has into stopping d5
that's when Knight g4 becomes a really
good move for black so last idea here is
Bishop g5 as I am slightly running over
time this would run into the move Bishop
e6 and the idea of Bishop g5 is to take
off this Knight preventing its control
of d5 from the start rather than keeping
this Bishop here on e
unfortunately I unfortunately for white
I just don't think that this trade is is
actually gonna be all that favorable for
a white I mean we saw Knight g4
threatening to take off this bishop in
another line so white doing it
voluntarily is slightly suspicious the
justification is that you get to play
Knight d5 immediately but now simply
Bishop g5 buy black and this Bishop is
going to be an active piece here
eventually we'll see this Knight really
has no opportunities where it's at so
it'll land on either c1 or d2 and
usually at that moment you do see black
take off in this night in exchange for
the bishop so it's not as though now
that the light the dark squared Bishop
is gone for white this Bishop is sort of
gonna be floating out in midair forever
because it will always have the
opportunity to sacrifice or I guess
trade itself off for the night on
currently on b3 just to continue an
example line here
a5 rook c8 Bishop out to g4 is a
sensible idea to try and prevent f5 and
now in a game played by Sergei Kuryakin
I believe against Alexander a rush era
Schenk oh he came up with the move
Knight B 8 here and this is sort of a
direct reply to how White has chosen to
treat this position because of the way
white has played he gave up this dark
squared bishop in exchange for this
knight on d5 and this Knight is doing an
adequate job of defending the beef for
square so the upside for white is b4 is
no longer really a problem for him
downside he did give up his dark squared
Bishop and that's why black goes Knight
be 8 here sort of admitting defeat on
the B 4 square and now rerouting this
Knight to a natural square the
compensation for this of course is that
this Bishop is still alive that game
continued with takes on e6
F takes c6 Knight b6 and now Ric c6 is a
great move to defend this pawn laterally
also pressured b6 night now after c3 the
point of this reroute becomes clear c6
is a better Square for the rook and this
night from d7 challenges this night and
now trades ensued in the game
they eventually agreed to a draw with
this position not really being any worse
for black with some b5 or potentially
even b6 ideas to follow okay so to recap
here we have a few different ideas in
this night b3 and castles line for white
we have in this Bishop e3 idea and that
we looked at and against Bishop e3
that's the green light to play Bishop e6
black is going to plie and be playing
Knight B to d7 aim for Knight b6 to c4
if white prevents this with prevents
this with a4 a5 preventing both b5 and
this idea of nine p6 that's when we go
to this idea of if I can find it here
of playing first Rick c8 sorry I'm
falling apart here
a5 Queen c7 and going for Knight c5
instead so main idea playing b5 in 9 p
6a for stops in ib 5 Wow the lines all
got a little bit messed up as they
sometimes do only chess a for preventing
B 5 and then a 5 preventing Knight b6
allows us to go for a tertiary plan I
got made fun of freezing that word once
but I'll continue to use it
tertiary plan of playing the move Knight
c5 this is the idea sort of against
Bishop e3 now white also has this clever
idea of playing the move 9 King h1 with
a waiting move waiting to see what black
does it fit should be 6 at 4 is strong
if b5 a for strong so black plays b6
instead and then either you'll see
Bishop e3 when we play Bishop e7 f3 and
only then b5 or you'll see a 4 and f3
when we once again after a 4 go for the
be 4 square third idea we looked at
tonight is the idea of playing the move
Queen to d3 and going for a quick Knight
to d5 and the way we play against this
is pretty natural just Bishop e6
and now if the immediate night d5 Knight
bt7 Bishop d2 going for the a5 square we
take off the Knights and play the move
98 going for counter play on the Kings
side and then finally the last idea that
we just took a look at to recap is this
idea of nine a four and once again we
fall back on these plans of playing
knight c6 to b4 going for a quick d5
these are the four major variations that
I introduce to you tonight hopefully
you're walking away with a good idea of
the plants and with a reasonable
understanding of the exact theory as
well thank you so much for joining me on
the inaugural episode of learn the
knight ourf with me Caleb and I will see
you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you